let's bring in Michael Wilbon co-host -
pardon the interruption also covers the
NBA for the mothership you can follow
him on twitter and instagram at real
mike will bond whooping how are you
today good LAN how you doing I'm doing
okay
I was hosted mr. Tony's nationals you
know what I mean he's uh he couldn't
actually still watch the games for
himself
technology had to help him the next
morning but as you know as I told you at
dinner last night I said you know you
you better figure out some way to
celebrate and join us because who knows
if it'll happen even though he'll have
you're one of your four aces or your MVP
third baseman you don't know where this
is going so you better you know stop
being sour and enjoy it and I don't know
if it registers wait wait did he not
stay up till the end of Game seven no no
and he vowed he would it was seven Dan
because you know there were there were
games in which you know what the drama
was crazy and was late and I called a
couple of times and his wife Carol said
we should I wake him I want to wake him
I'm like I know but he's gonna go nuts
he's got to get up at 3:15 the milk cows
and he so buddy said he was gonna watch
seven I think you got five innings
no not even seven I mentioned this
yesterday where it feels like I know
less now than I did a month ago with the
NFL like here we are at the halfway
point i I don't I don't know what I'm
supposed to know right now who's great
who's not who should we believe looking
out for in the fertile second half they
had an easy schedule in the first half
he sold on Garoppolo with the Niners you
know the Cowboys where do you stand on
the halfway point in the NFL season
um Dan I think that's because that's
what had that reaction a week ago I
think it's because this is a lot of bad
football and people don't talk about
that they'll talk about it as bad
basketball talk about the baseball
season has something wrong they don't
want to talk they don't wanna deal with
that with the football they just want
their football they don't want to
examine the quality of it it was a lot
of bad football but I mean I think to
see I think I know I actually think I do
know the San Francisco is
this good I mean just good meaning not
sixteen oh good but I don't know 14 and
- good
and I think despite the Patriots lose in
the game they're gonna still be 13 and 3
or whatever you know I'm happy I think
the teams that we trust are few and far
between but that's okay because it's
viewing far between have they earned our
trust and there's some teams out there
that are just I don't know just ought to
be wildly disappointed in the seasons
they're having and that one of those
teams is the wire in Chicago which I
have Rhoda for my entire life and the
Cleveland Brown headline they showed in
me because everybody was so stupid as to
invest a level of trust in them as if
they were into a Steel Curtain or some
great team from a bygone era
the Cleveland Browns like what do you
what do you people seeing what are you
putting your trust in but I think
because they're more of those teams in
that second group that we sweet were
still hesitant but I think we know where
the good teams are now yeah but Mike if
Cleveland goes five and three in the
second half of the season they end up
eight and eight which is a game better
than last year
that's improving obviously but that's
that'll be a disappointment in Cleveland
this time it will be how make certain to
go five and three I don't only they're
any good now their schedule lightens up
a little yeah so maybe they can maybe
that's manageable but they made four
team that actually believed its own hype
and the quarterback that they've got I
mean I think that's still a massive
disappointment for them
anything less to make in the playoffs
with the way they started and they
believed it clearly did they brought all
the hype themselves and it's like really
and baby Freddie kitchens is just in
over his head and this was too much for
him but I certainly you know I just sort
of love seeing what's happening as a
proud you know what they saw themselves
coming into the season if I if I gave
you the power to pull the ripcord on
Mitchell true Biscay you bring in
I'll give you Andy Dalton but you say
goodbye to Mitchell true biscuit yep
done and Dan I was not a true Biscay guy
from the beginning I'm at
I'd live mostly here in Washington an
ACC country so true Brisky was not as
foreign a name to people who live a
watch ACC football a little bit and he
might have been to other people he only
had whenever it was ten or eleven starts
and I saw some of them and I just
thought why are they trading up to get
this guy if you think you see something
and you want to take him five there's no
one battling for position to Jeff
Mitchell Xu Biscay why are you giving
with other people in the form of draft
picks who should be Pro Bowlers but Mike
the bearers were in competition with
common sense that's who they were
fighting yes they're fighting common
sense to trade up to get Mitchell true
Biscay junior how did you watch how can
you how can you do this professionally I
think I know the answer after you do
this professionally Dan and you take
Mitchell true Brisky over both deshaun
Watson and Patrick mom's it's it's read
out I mean Watson to me didn't make any
that you can't pass up on him III know
that you know everybody now revisionist
history with my homes and I give back
you know all the credit to Andy Reed
because he saw it he played his cards
great there was mixed reviews deshaun
Watson was everything that you asked in
a quarterback he's smart good kid he was
big in big games they've been at the
previous level what he could do yeah and
and you know what Mitchell true Biscay
was like I look at Mitchell too risky
the way I do Daniel Jones
if I watch your games and I don't
remember you know it's it's not and that
was the point that I was like and you
traded up to get him pick it up that's
the part that trading up makes it just
egregious egregious mistake and and you
know people so now today and I see these
questions you know probably's panels
whatever network that's talking about
pro football and it's do the Bears have
to stay with Mitchell tree Biscay of
course they do they don't have anybody
else
chase daniels is that up a real
quarterback if he was he would have
played sometimes
2015 no draft mix either and no draft
picks and no money because you're
committed it all elsewhere and and by
the way it's understandable that you
don't have those things cuz you when
they rested last year they thought they
had all the pieces and it looked like
they did and I let me say this about the
true Biscay episode I'm not so sure true
Biscay can't play for anybody I think
the bigger problem in Chicago the bigger
problem is the head coach and don't tell
me that somebody's got to fit your
system this is what I think is the
biggest problem in the NFL now as I look
through the coach here I see stuff like
I mean Matt Patricia somebody that
people think really can't coach how do
you run that place down after the
Raiders have stupidly called timeout Jon
Gruden and you don't have gamma day on
the field how do you do that how is that
how does that guy not skewered because
people don't even criticize the coaches
they just go watch the players you see
the head coaching to me is as bad as
it's ever been in my lifetime in the NFL
he's Michael Wilbon pardon the
interruption co-host covers the NBA as
well for ESPN and ABC speaking of which
Reggie Miller is on in a little more a
little less than an hour and after
LeBrons performance against Dallas I
text reg to say this is why LeBron is
better than Kawhi Leonard and he came
back and said you know Kawhi career year
I said LeBrons career averages are wise
career year yeah if Kawhi didn't win the
NBA title okay
would we be had this coronation that
he's the best player in the NBA
nobody did I know but it feels like Dan
I'm kind of like I would take LeBron
with you either take LeBron this year I
think LeBron is going to be he's playing
defense he's in better shape
he's got Anthony Davis and I think he's
he's a little bit of an underdog this
year and I think that's a dangerous
place for LeBron I think that works for
him in a lot of ways yes yes yes I agree
with every one of those check check
check
but why Dan here's where this is why I
will never
go all-in with analytics or the use of
any numbers Kawhi Leonard has a greater
impact on a game on both in to the floor
than anybody in the game today and last
year he's when he's out there I am about
load management and I know that LeBron
look collides out of our Mount Rushmore
basketball LeBron is but what I saw how
I do with my own eyes lash you remember
this if the San Antonio Spurs get a
rebound one rebound late in the game in
the last nine seconds yeah
Kawhi Leonard has three titles and
LeBron has two and what will we will we
say then what will we say about the
whole thing I mean it's I but I do agree
with you that I think LeBron is if he
physically holds up and I've had more
people question that could like just
older guys you and I covered forever
they say to me occasionally hey hey I
know what it feels like to try to do
this 35 or 36 be careful and there's
that that warning is out there and I'm
going okay let me let me slow my roll
just a little but I think I agree with
you about LeBron by the way is it aside
in that game didn't you decide that Luca
dance which is one of the five best
players in the game right now when you
watch that that Laker Dallas came here
tonight I always I look at somebody and
say is the moment too big for you
and it felt like I could see that he
embraced the moment he's going against
his idol and not not nervous or afraid
at all taking it to LeBron step-back
three right in his face and I went okay
now now you have a ride this isn't one
of those a cute little curiosity guide
down there in Dallas now it's come on in
you know I travel I'll go put on a show
at your place as well his ability to in
in I think intelligence is really what
sometimes lost on these great players
you know Jordan was one of the most
intelligent players I was ever around
bird got more credit and he was the
cerebral one Mike was intelligent so was
magic
LeBron extremely bright dhansak sees the
game and you can see that we're you know
he's thinking out there and
I'll make sense what he's doing and
LeBron commented on that postgame
I think doors Burke asked him and he
went there right away about the way he
plays in what he sees yeah it's fun it's
it's it's fun to watch of the Kauai
thing it's a conundrum for a lot of
people damn because he does not have the
immeasurables that everybody has to have
now in order to make a certain argument
and my argument is okay this guy just
wins the game like whatever he has to do
and you can I was reminded of it really
in the Milwaukee series and like yep yep
yep yep he's the best player on the
floor and now is the best for the league
I don't I don't know I'm sort of just
shy of that like okay when you take him
over the Greek freak yeah cuz the freak
hasn't showed me one thing in the next
six to eight weeks they don't show me
right now the jumper yep your jumper Dan
oh my god pregame shows he's gonna have
to be three it definitely three point
deep Dan and then gotta be 14 16 feet so
people can't walk him off because I
don't know if the Greek freak is better
than Anthony Davis when bowlinator
okay because Anthony Davis does have
range he's great at the line and they're
both similar in size now the Greek freak
probably better all-around player you
know with assists and blocks and still
known as Anthony Davis we forgot about
and now people are getting reintroduced
to him because now he's playing on a big
stage anything with a guy who can look
in juggling out the best weight off of
them absolutely yeah they're still great
as that whole list of guys is that your
mission and you know there's still a
couple of questions and maybe they're
minor questions without question and
freaks heart or anything like that but
he's got to have by the time we get to
April
we better see that shot so that when
when they do what Toronto did to him and
in the playoffs last year he can say
fine step off me I'll hit this and so
I'm looking forward to see whether he
made that that adjustment had to have
been made over the summer we can't be
like you can't be like my man on Philly
who
just afraid to you just can't pull a
trigger on jumpshot the guys want to
know they were asked me yesterday about
Stephen a Smith's game and and we were
around Stephen a when we cover the NBA
Finals so you've seen both our shots if
it's you and your journalist if there's
a shooting contest between myself and
Stephen a Smith where's your money
listen I'm doing straight stereotype I
got to take the old white it just became
racial Wow seriously Dan you know what
I've seen you play much more and
certainly going back to when you were
still we nippy Wiest we all you know
what do nb8 people cover the league they
don't play pickup anymore we used to
have to play pick-up night well you know
why that is though and so I haven't seen
Stephen a play as much as you would
think even though we spend so much time
together but then we first of all we
were allowed into practice we were not
there in suits and ties we were there in
sweats to shoot around or whatever a
practice and then you had to actually
play with like guys who didn't get any
minutes remember that that doesn't
happen
like do we know if anybody cousin Lee
can play anymore I don't know but I know
that there was the I think the Marriott
Downtown in Chicago when the Bulls were
in the finals and we played a basketball
game there Jackie McMullen Ric Bucher
and it was on man I loved it I was like
it was great I mean I Rick Mahorn
reminded me of that recently because he
asked the question and he just said we
played all the time and of course it was
green on me early on in my career as a
sports writer I think I woke up three
minutes later and more loved it that I
laughed at it and and and treasured it I
did because I wasn't good enough to be
worried about the skill stuff and what
Warren said we used to play all the time
that people who covered the league and I
said yeah I think that like everything
else good I think that's gone but I'm
I'm taking I'm taking you on the jump
shot all right all right
and I sprained ankles I don't like to
break him
I will post up Rachel Nichols okay high
five three Rachel I will poster up Lee
I'm taking you on that too
hey Mike good to talk to you thanks for
joining us as always thanks for having
me sure Michael Wilbon Wilbon pardon the
interruption 5:30 Eastern Monday through
Friday for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]